here's a really weird voicemail or voicemail
number of course.
Two, one nine two David P take a listen to
this strange voicemail about my relationships
with older men.
I don't know what this is about,
David.
Um, you have been very open about your, um,
sort of your relationship with much older
men.
Um, I mean, you're talking about men twice
and sometimes three times your own age.
You're seeing, and I'm just wanting to say,
you know, you're such an American hero for
doing that, Dave.
Um, I just want to yell personally, thank
you for coming out and being so honest with
your audience.
And some people would say, you know, it's
completely inappropriate to be discussing
these sort of things.
I'm on a radio politics talk show program,
but you know what, Dave, I'm not one of those
people.
I just want to personally thank you for being
so open and honest about your homosexuality.
And, uh,
he the best in the future.
Thank you.
I don't know what you're talking about, but
I appreciate the kind of wishes.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Become a member, become a patron to get instant
access to that bonus.
Show the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].